Welcome back to State of the Union
I'm Jake Tapper.
There is a new battle
brewing between top House Republicans
and the man leading
the Trump hush money
investigation in New York.
Manhattan District Attorney
Alban Bragg's office is accusing
three GOP House
chairmen
of trying to interfere
in a local investigation
as they renew
their demands that he testify
about his current probe
of former President Trump.
Joining me now is one of the Rep
behind the request,
the chairman of the House
Oversight Committee,
Congressman James Colmer,
Republican of Kentucky.
Mr.
Chairman, thanks so much for joi
You just wrote a new letter
to Manhattan D.A.
Bragg defending your decision
to investigate his office,
saying that you're considering
taking legislative action
to prevent
presidents from, quote, politica
motivated prosecutions as of rig
Of course,
Trump has not been charged with
What do you say to Bragg who say
trying to stop a charge from hap
even before you know of any evid
Well, what the D.A.
is trying to say is what you jus
He said, stay
out of local investigations.
The problem with that is
this is not a local investigatio
This is a federal investigation.
He's investigating
a presidential candidate, not to
former president of the United S
for a federal election crime.
That has no business
being litigated
in a local district attorney's o
And when he says he's
not going to cooperate with Cong
Unfortunately for Mr.
Bragg,
he doesn't have the luxury of de
whether or not
he can comply with congressional
because he crossed over
two levels of government
from the local level to the fede
to try to prosecute something th
that clearly,
if there was a reason
for prosecution
it should be done
by the Department of Justice
on the federal level.
Well, he's investigating,
as I understand it, potential
violations of state crimes
even at that.
Look, let's let's just be honest
This is about politics.
This is a presidential candidate
When you look at what
we believe the role of the Manha
should be is to fight crime.
I mean, that's
one of the biggest issues in New
We saw that in the midterm
elections last November.
Voters overwhelmingly rejected
many Democrat candidates
because of the crime issue.
We have a crime crisis
in many of our cities.
We're trying to do something abo
in the House of Representatives.
And one of the reasons
we believe
we have high crime
rates in certain parts of Americ
because we have prosecutors
that are soft on crime
and we believe that our tax doll
And that's where I come in with
Oversight Committee.
We believe tax
dollars would be better spent
prosecuting local criminals.
That's what the DEA is supposed
Are you arguing that
people who commit business crime
not committing crimes
Look.
Well, is this a business crime?
We're talking about a federal el
crime here.
This is a federal election crime
The Manhattan D.A.
does not write federal election.
My understanding is finalized.
My understanding
is that
he is being investigated
for falsifying business records.
It's you know,
there was a related prosecution.
Michael Cohen went to prison.
That was a federal investigation
from the U.S.
attorney during the Trump years.
But that U.S. attorney Mr.
Berman prosecuted and Mr.
Khuzami prosecuted Michael Cohen
He went to prison for that.
That as well as related crimes.
I don't remember
hearing anything from you
during that period.
I guess he wasn't a candidate,
but he had been working for Dona
that was a U.S.
attorney that prosecuted.
We're talking about a local atto
and the.
And look,
if you open a can of worms here,
what's going to happen.
You're going to have county atto
in in red areas in parts of Kent
rural Kentucky, where I am.
They're going to start
trying to overreach into
in a federal election law.
This is something that
if it needs to be investigated
or prosecuted,
it should be done on the federal
by the Department of Justice.
This is a presidential kind of w
one frustration
Republicans have in Congress
is that
we keep having
interference in our elections.
I know the Democrats complain
about that, rightfully so.
When James Comey
just a few weeks or a few days
before the presidential election
said that Hillary
was being investigated
for mishandling e-mails.
Look, that shouldn't have happen
That shouldn't have happened.
And we keep having stuff
like this happen in our election
We just want the government
out of our elections.
We don't believe tax
dollars should be spent for this
We believe this is a political s
But Mr.
Bragg,
we believe the statute of limita
has expired on all of this stuff
Clearly, if there's something
that rises to criminal level,
then then that should be done
on the federal level.
He hasn't
I mean,
you keep asserting
what this investigation is
and we haven't seen an indictmen
We haven't seen charges.
We haven't seen evidence.
What if District Attorney Bragg
comes forward
with an indictment
with evidence and proof that Don
did commit these crimes?
You still think he shouldn't be
Well, we
believe that he should come expl
exactly what he's investigating,
because at the end of the day,
this is a presidential candidate
This is the
for better
or worse,
leading contender
for the Republican nomination
of the presidential election nex
as well as a former president
and I think
it's unprecedented
for a local district attorney
to investigate things
that we believe
the statute of limitations
expired years ago now.
Look, if
if the special counsel
that's looking into
this wants to do something,
if if the Department of Justice
wants to do something,
then then they probably for bett
or worse, have the ability to do
This is a local D.A.
We believe the local D.A.
need to be focused on business
crimes, on burglary,
on their own, on carjack gangs
and all the things that we see h
in these big cities that are
that are creating
a crime crisis in America.
So a lot of your fellow Republic
on the Senate side
seem to be concerned about what
you and your
your fellow committee
chairmen in the House side are d
Senator John Cornyn of Texas
said, quote,
I personally prefer to see them
work on the agenda they ran on
and that got them the majority.
Senator Thom
Tillis of North Carolina said,
I think you've got to fall short
of getting involved in the legal
Senator Jerry Moran,
Kansas, said,
you want to know lots of facts
before you set down that path.
They seem to think
that you and your colleagues are
way beyond
looking into the use of federal
and are risking
interfering in a local investiga
of a private citizen
allegedly accused of committing
that someone's
already going to prison for
Again, this is a local investiga
It's it's
not a sincere argument
to say it's a local investigatio
when you're investigating
a presidential candidate
and the former president, United
Again, we believe that
this should be done
on the on the federal level.
We don't believe this is a good
of tax dollars.
And if Mr.
Bragg want to come in and explai
what he what he's doing,
and he makes a good explanation.
He makes a good argument.
And we see that we're in an area
where we shouldn't belong,
such as the republic.
Some of the Republican senators
then we'll back off.
But we are sick and tired of med
in federal elections.
And I don't believe
that Bragg would be doing this
if Donald Trump
were not running for president.
And that's something
that we would like to ask Mr.
Bragg as well.
Would you be doing this
if he weren't a declared candida
for president,
for president United States?
If so, if this is the reason to
then this is a political investi
And we, again, desperately want
the Department of
Justice from meddling
in presidential elections.
Oh, I thought the issue was that
it was a local prosecutor,
not the Department of Justice.
But let me ask you,
if he refuses to come in
willingly, will you subpoena him
Well, that'll be up to Jim Jorda
I mean, he's
the lead
investigator
in this particular situation.
I come in as oversight
because it deals with unnecessar
use of tax dollars.
Chairman Steele is head of House
administration.
He's in charge of elections.
That's why the three of us were
that signed the letter.
But Jim
Jordan is the is the lead
and he would be the one
to answer that question.
Jim Jordan, who refused to compl
with a congressional subpoena
in the previous Congress
Jim Jordan, the chairman of
the House Judiciary Committee.
All right,
Chairman Kummer,
good to see you as always.
Thank you so much, sir. Apprecia